on va maintenant accéder au fameux
plastique et là des principaux polluants
de la planète vous le savez on le trouve
partout jusque dans le fond des océans
et maintenant il ya de nouvelles études
qui montrent qu'on le retrouve aussi
dans notre assiette dans ce qu'on mange
à des chercheurs canadiens ont calculé
le nombre de de particules de plastique
chaque année qu'on ingère c'est sûr
qu'il ya des risques pour la santé on va
parler de cette étude là avec renault
manuguerra gagné bonjour renault bonjour
caroline
comment est-ce que du plastique peut se
retrouver dans nos aliments
d'abord vous rappeler qu'on parle de
plastique cdp est conventionné 6 cd
microplastiques donc céder tout petites
particules entre la taille d'un grain de
riz est une bactérie généralement
quelque chose aussi fin qu'un cheveu
humain
non ça se voit c'est très rare que ça se
voit les humains ces microparticules
c'est des débris donc dès qu'ils vont se
détacher plus gros objets comme des sacs
en plastique des bouteilles des fibres
de polyester qui peuvent se détacher nos
vêtements par exemple qu'on les laisse à
la sécheuse
donc ceux celles atteleyn le type de
pollution plastique qui la plus commune
à travers le monde on la retrouve
vraiment partout dans le fond des océans
elle va entrer à cet endroit là dans la
chaîne alimentaire c'est pour ça qu'on
les retrouve à l'intérieur certains
fruits de mer dans des poissons est là
cette poussière de plastique là ça peut
aussi contaminé certains aliments comme
du sel ou du sucre donc il ya plus il ya
beaucoup d'études jusqu'à maintenant
qu'ils ont montré la présence de
plastiques la microscopique dans
certains aliments
donc les chercheurs canadiens de
l'université victoria en
colombie-britannique ont voulu faire un
premier bilan global de notre
consommation annuelle de plastique et
donc ils ont récupéré 26 études qui
regardaient chacun de chacun un aliment
et ils ont remarqué que quand vous
regardez la présence de ces aliments là
dans notre consommation annuelle ça
faisait qu'on peut ingérer entre 74 et
121 mille particules microparticules de
plastique à chaque année soit un chiffre
qui est assez impressionnant un stage
chef qui est énorme mais là les
chercheurs disent que c'est même un chef
qui est sous-estimée oui on pense que si
on peut en avoir encore plus que 53 pour
trois raisons majeures
oui ça c'est décourageant quand même et
les raisons c'est que d'abord les
aliments que les chercheurs ont évalué
dans leur étude représente seulement 15%
de notre apport calorique annuel donc il
pas pu vérifier la présence de plastique
dans d'autres viandes comme la volaille
ou la viande rouge sa présence dans les
produits laitiers sa présence dans les
céréales ou d'autres produits qui
pourraient être éventuellement
contaminés officiellement caisse % des
aliments qu'on mange qui ont été
étudiées c'est ça parce que les études
on y lisons pour les autres aliments
mais les études existent tout simplement
pas à l'heure actuelle donc c'est pour
ça que on pourrait en avoir beaucoup
plus
il ya aussi le fait qu'il ya beaucoup de
variations d'une personne à l'autre par
exemple un des éléments qui apporte le
plus de particules de plastique dans le
cas que les chercheurs ont découvert ces
les bouteilles d'eau donc les quelqu'un
qui utilise beaucoup de bouteilles d'eau
dans son année pourrait se retrouver à
ajouter 100 mille particules de plus
dans son cas c'est ça notre problème est
finalement ces particules se retrouve
aussi dans l'air qu'on respire donc l'on
parle de particules qui sont très fines
qui ont de très petite taille peut être
porté par le vin sur des grandes
distances et donc on peut les respirer
elles sont passées pour la plupart sont
pas assez fine pour ce conte très loin
dans les poumons mais vous avez vont
être rejetés se retrouver dans notre
gorge husky et c'est ce qui fait qu'on
peut la vallée en contrepartie est-ce
qu'on va utiliser les impacts sur la
santé mais on aimerait ça le ferait pour
l'instant il n'y a pas d'étude humaine
qui ont réussi qui ont évalué 7 cet
impact le tout simplement parce qu'on
n'était pas au courant qu'ils en avaient
autant il ya certains chercheurs qui
pense que ça pourrait ne pas porter de
risque est que ces particules
impressionnant traversy le système
digestif est rejetée à la sortie mais il
ya d'autres choses qui sont moins
certain donc dont les chercheurs
canadiens qui rappelle par exemple que
certaines peuvent être assez fine pour
entrer dans les tissus humains se
retrouver dans la circulation sanguine
et là il pourrait faire de l'un beaucoup
d'inflammation ont ces particules de
plastique là peuvent aussi être combinée
à certaines molécules nocives comme les
retardateurs de flamme ou des
perturbateurs endocriniens
donc ça pourrait être éventuellement
causer problème pour la santé
par contre les études qui l'ont montré
ont toutes été faites chez l'animal ou
est-ce que la sécomile à être exposés à
beaucoup plus de plastique que ce qu'on
croit qu'ils se retrouvent dans
l'alimentation humaine
c'est pour ça que cette incertitude est
que les chercheurs veulent faire plus
d'études
c'est là à déterminer alors qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire à part de ça et aux
plats salés les chars du côté des
chercheurs veulent faire plus d'études
pressé de voir cet effet le surtout à
l'échelle d'une vie c'est là que ça
pourrait peut-être problématique et pour
la population générale
les chercheurs recommandent essaie de
diminuer sa consommation éviter les
produits à risque comme les bouteilles
de plastique et les produits suremballés
c'est peut-être un signe qu'il faudrait
justement qu'on ait plus de d'exiger en
fait de nouvelles mesures de contrôle
pour les produits suremballés en
plastique parce que le c'est vrai que
c'est un ça commençait d'un problème
qu'on commence à manger sans
consentement
ça me fait prendre conscience de tout ça
encore plus ce matin merci beaucoup
renault reprises et on vous propose
d'ailleurs un grand dossier sur ici
radio canada.ca l'ennemi plastique
il a fallu cent ans finalement pour que
ce matériau là qui était quasi est
inexistant deviennent omniprésents dans
notre quotidien et c'est devenu vraiment
un pollueur très très important de la
planète bruxelles